هو اول فعلا همم واعظ يحظى بشعبيه تغير
كان في قبله الباقوري والباقولي انت عارف
من ايام جمال عبد الناصر من ايام الثوره
كان موجود مع رجال الثوره مع وزيرا اصبح
وزيرا للاوقاف في 52 يعني معهد الثوره على
طول المهم وكان ايضا شخصيه لها يعني سمي
حولها حب ولكن ولكن اللي عمل النجاح
الطاغي قوي ده كان شيخ الشعراوي يعني في
شيوخ كتيره حوله كان على الجانب الاخر كان
فيه الشيخ كشك بس الشيخ كشك كان كفيف
نجوميته عن فريق الكاسيت يعني واكب الشيخ
كشك شريط الكاسيت فاصبح ظاهره صوتيه وكان
دمه خفيف برضو كويس بس الشيخ الشعراوي من
خلال التلفزيون المصري الكلام ده قبل
الفضائيات انت عارف قبل الفضائيات كان لو
عملت برنامج كل الدنيا اتفرج عليك الفضيات
لا انت بتتكلم على 3000 فضائيه يعني عامل
الندره هناك هو اللي يعطي الوهج اكثر
مزبوط وكان برنامج لاحمد فراج ده مذيع
مصري معروف اتهم من الشخصيه دي احمد فرج
البعض يقول انه هو اللي قدم الشعراوي الى
المشهد التلفزيوني يعني عرف الجماهير
بالشعراوي مزبوط يعني هو كان بيستفيد من
شيوخ وكان برنامج نور على نور ده برنامج
كل مصر في التلفزيون الارضي بعد صلاه
الجمعه تقعد تتفرج على احمد رجب مذيع ناجح
قطعا وكان طبعا حقق شهره طاغيه بالذات بعد
زواجه من صباح الفنانه صباح رغم انه شخص
محافظ وغنيت له الحلو ليه زعلان قوي وكل
حاجه يعني
ويمثل معها وكان شخصيه محافزه ولكن قدرت
تاخده ناحيتها بس
التلاته يحبونا كان واحد من الثلاثه كويس
جريئه واحده بتتغزل في رجل حلو ليه ثقلان
قوي دايما الراجل بيتغزل في امراه لكن هو
كان وسيم طبعا وكان مطلعها بعد كده وحتى
حد احد الجمهور بعث له رساله ونزلت في
الجرائد قال له طلاقك من صباح نور على نور
على اسم البرنامج
هو هو الذي عرف الجمهور بالشعراء لانه
برنامج ناجح ولكن كل اسبوع بيستضيف حد
فالمهم لما وكان بيغير الدعاه لكن اللي خد
الثبات بناء على ايه انه بدا يحس ان في
مردود جماهيري لان البرنامج كان توكشه
يعني كان بيبقى كمان في ناس موجودين في
الاستوديو يسالوا اسئله فلقوا ان شيخ
الشعراوي كاريزماتيك ودي طبعا بتاعه ربنا
حد يعني ايه ينكرها على الرجل
عنده كاريزما ودمه خفيف وعنده حضور وطبعا
مثقف دينيا ولغويا
شهره عريضه